we're approaching the end game of
Avengers end game Marvel launches the
re-release of the superhero flick Friday
June 28th though the secretive studio
has revealed some information about the
new content fans can expect to see with
the re-release Marvel has kept quiet on
the never-before-seen footage fans have
been most excited for a quote unfinished
deleted scene that we'll play after the
credits Marvel fans everywhere have
tossed around theories left and right
about what they might witness in the
re-release post-credit scene but thanks
to a recent report from we got this
covered we may now have the answer as to
what the sequence actually is reportedly
the post-credits scene featured in the
avengers endgame re-release is focused
on Mark Ruffalo's professor Hulk unnamed
sources close to the outlet claim that
the sequence is about a minute long and
isn't the type of deleted scene that
some viewers have been anticipating the
scene which Marvel itself has confirmed
is incomplete and was cut from the
theatrical version of endgame is said to
show professor Hulk coming to the rescue
when a group of children are in danger
leaping into action the big green guy
jumps into a burning building and
rescues the youngsters then the scene
ends though it sounds like a fun scene
the sequence is perhaps more notable for
what it isn't than what it is it's not
for instance 80s to set up events in
Marvel's upcoming phase 4 which is still
shrouded in mystery it's not about
Captain America's trip to the past and
it also doesn't reveal any hints about
Hulk's future in the MCU which given how
likable the character is is fairly
disappointing like fire real fire raging
fire like smoldering fire the purported
endgame rerelease post-credits scene
also isn't the much-discussed deleted
sequence featuring Catherine Lankford as
an older Morgan Stark Lankford who most
know is Hannah Baker on Netflix is Drama
Series 13 reasons why filmed the scene
in which Morgan Stark appeared in front
of her father Robert Downey jr. 'he's
Tony Stark after he snaps his fingers
using the Avengers infinity gauntlet his
health quickly fading after powering the
gauntlet to defeat Thanos and his army
Tony's consciousness travels to a
metaphysical weigh station where he sees
his daughter now much older than she
appeared throughout avengers endgame who
forgives him for making the ultimate
sacrifice and
leaving her to grow up without a father
the sequence is presumably an echo of
the scene from Avengers infinity war
where Thanos visits the spirit realm to
meet the ghost of the daughter he
murdered Gamora did it cost
[Music]
very soon
[Music]
directors Joe and Anthony Russo clipped
the Morgan Stark seen from endgame
because they felt it made the already
complicated movie even more complex but
some fans had pinned their hopes on
seeing it in the re-release if we got
this covered support is to be believed
though this scene won't ever roll out on
the big screen still there's some hope
that fans will eventually get to see
that sequence Avengers endgame is set to
be released digitally on July 30th and
on blu-ray on August 13th and it's very
likely that the bonus material for those
releases will feature deleted and
extended scenes hopefully including the
Morgan Stark scene and even if the
purported professor Hulk's sequence
isn't the post-credits scene you were
hoping for there are still plenty of
other reasons to see the end game
re-release in theaters even though the
re-release is not actually an extended
cut it does reportedly include a new
introduction from co-director Anthony
Russo as well as a tribute that's
believed to honor the late Stan Lee plus
a sneak peek at spider-man far from home
plus for the first wave of fans there
will be a limited number of exclusive
free posters featuring an illustration
of the Infinity Gauntlet with a
bittersweet phrase we love you 3,000
stamped along the bottom plus you know
there's the movie itself which is
awesome the second time or the 30th
hopefully all that will be enough to
make up for what could be a pretty
unremarkable post-credit scene in The
Avengers and game re-release check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite Marvel films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]